[Music]
see that bright object in the sky
that's Andromeda the closest major
galaxy to our Milky Way and the most
distant thing you can see with the naked
eye and it's racing towards us at the
rate of 110 kilometers per second
eventually four billion years from now
Andromeda will merge with our Milky Way
in a huge galactic collision but what if
these galaxies were to collide tomorrow
what all the stars and planets suddenly
plow into each other could our solar
system survive this massive crash and
what would this galactic light show look
like from Earth this is what if and
here's what would happen if the Milky
Way and the Andromeda galaxy collided
there are at least 100 billion galaxies
in the observable universe all colliding
with each other larger galaxies merge
about every 9 billion years while
smaller ones slam into each other even
more often
wait what about dark energy isn't this
hypothesized force pulling the universe
and everything in it apart it sure is
for nearby galaxies though gravity takes
over Andromeda and the Milky Way are no
exception
they both contains central supermassive
black holes that will eventually mesh
the two star systems together imagine if
that gigantic collision were to happen
tomorrow what would that look like
Andromeda is pretty far away it couldn't
just overcome a distance of two and a
half million light-years in a single day
let's assume that somehow the
supermassive black hole in the center of
the Milky Way increased its
gravitational pull on Andromeda's black
hole and the Big Crunch happened four
billion years earlier than expected
what's next first there would be no
Milky Way and no Andromeda the two
spiral galaxies would become a totally
different type of galaxy an elliptical
one you can call the new galaxy milk
Amanda or milk dromeda which ever one
you prefer
once Andromeda invaded Milky Way's
personal space the Sun and our entire
solar system would be forced to the
outskirts of the newly formed galaxy
26,000 light years further away and
that's the best case scenario in the
worst case one we might end up in a
galactic Siberia
160,000 light years away from mill
Commodus center what about all the stars
in both galaxies would they collide with
each other
some of them would but even though Milky
Way counts around 250 billion stars and
Andromeda has over a trillion of them
all these stars are separated by light
years of empty space it's unlikely that
many of them would merge instead they
just get scattered into different orbits
whoo I forgot to mention we invited a
third galaxy to this party the
Triangulum galaxy or m33 a smaller
satellite galaxy of Andromeda this is
shaping up to be a massive khalaqtu mash
up for us earthlings this would look
just incredible the bright core of the
new super galaxy would set the night sky
ablaze eventually the two supermassive
black holes at the center of these
galaxies would come so close to each
other that they themselves would merge
all the gas taken up by this monstrous
black hole would form a bright quasar at
the center of the galaxy another
spectacular show for us here on earth
too bad in reality our planet won't live
long enough to see any of it by the time
Andromeda slams into the Milky Way the
Sun would have already turned into a red
giant and swallowed up the entire earth
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]